okay which of the following statements
about specific energy is true a the
specific energy equation is only
applicable to closed conduit flow B the
variables in the specific energy
equation are independent of the geometry
of the channel C the specific energy
equation is used to determine the depth
of flow for a given flow rate and
channel
velocity and channel geometry so
sorry D the specific energy equation is
not affected by the velocity of the
fluid so obviously this here is a
conceptual
problem um one thing we can still do if
we want is check out the specific energy
equation in the manual and see if
there's anything that that will help us
out with so if you look up this equation
we can see that E equals
Alpha q^
2ar over
2G a^ 2 quantity +
y so let's start looking at each of the
options here and determine if we can
prove any of these to be false so a the
specific energy equation is only
applicable to closed conduit
flow um I don't think this can be proven
based on the equation but it is known
for a fact that this is also applicable
to open Channel flow so
[Music]
false B the variables in the specific
energy equation are independent of the
geometry of the
channel I would say false here as well
because we have an area term and we also
have a Q term Q which which is going to
be based on V * a
so C the specific energy equation is
used to determine the depth of flow for
a given flow rate and channel velocity
sorry Channel
geometry so if we look up the drawing in
the manual as well for a specific energy
equation we can see a real
easy example here so we have our line of
constant
flow we have our depth over here and we
have our specific energy along the
bottom
so if we have the known flow value and
we know the specific energy
up at this point where it intersects
with the flow this does give us a
depth
so this statement is technically true
the specific energy
equation can be used to determine the
depth of flow for a given flow rate and
channel
geometry and then finally we've got D
specific energy equation is not affected
by the velocity of the fluid I would say
that one is false as well simply because
again we have
q
and Q is based on V * a so it can't be
independent of
velocity so our answer here is going to
be
c um sometimes with questions like these
in the manual or with questions like
these on the exam rather
you can use some of what's in the manual
to narrow down your answers on occasion
a conceptual question on the PE is going
to be something that you simply have to
know but other times the question is
more testing you on whether or not you
understand the theory behind a given
equation so if you can sort of put two
and two together based on what the
manual gives you and what something is
asking you can still get yourself to the
right answer and that's it for this
problem